[SPEAKER_00]: [Automatic captions by Autotekst using OpenAI Whisper V3. May contain recognition errors.] Avec le colloïde, vous pouvez voir ce qui se passe. Et puis les gens peuvent en
[SPEAKER_00]: parler. Mais ce que je sais de l'Orikami, c'est qu'il reviendra à son forme originale. Cela signifie que c'est comme une éponge, comme de
[SPEAKER_00]: l'air. C'est élastique, donc vous avez un rebond. Je ne comprends pas vraiment comment il peut absorber l'énergie comme le colloïde le fait.
[SPEAKER_00]: La deuxième chose, l'Orikami est Et ce genre de marques font de grands fabricants. Et ces grands fabricants produisent pour de nombreux
[SPEAKER_00]: petits marques. Généralement...
[SPEAKER_01]: Merci d'être venu, Eric. J'ai envie d'être en contact avec toi ou quelqu'un de ton équipe pendant longtemps pour avoir une idée de Flyneo
[SPEAKER_01]: Atelier. Expliquez-nous à nos auditeurs ce que c'est que Flyneo Atelier. Et Atelier, ça a l'air d'être un nom vraiment amusant. Comment
[SPEAKER_01]: avez-vous choisi le nom et quelle est votre marque ? Le nom est Néo. Ce n'est pas Néo Atelier, c'est juste une question d'URL et d'ID pour
[SPEAKER_00]: Internet. Mais le nom de la marque est juste Néo. On a mis Atelier pour dire que nous ne sommes pas un grand workshop asiatique. Nous sommes 30
[SPEAKER_00]: personnes qui travaillent comme un petit atelier. Nous sommes aussi Atelier parce que nous désignons tout et nous produisons tout dans
[SPEAKER_00]: notre workshop en France, Néo. Néo est venu de l'idée que les marques ne sont pas uniquement dans le paragliding, mais dans la plupart des
[SPEAKER_00]: sports à l'extérieur. Elles créent des designs, des couleurs, des fonctions, et elles envoient tout ça à l'Asie, où les vrais designers
[SPEAKER_00]: font les matières, produisent là-bas, importent et vendent en Europe. Elles considèrent que les grandes marques sont plutôt des personnes de
[SPEAKER_00]: marketing ou des personnes de design, qui sont vraiment bonnes pour vendre des produits, mais elles ne savent pas comment les faire avec
[SPEAKER_00]: leur propre main, comme un craftsman. Et Néo est ce que nous désignons. Nous produisons en France, nous vendons et nous faisons les
[SPEAKER_00]: certifications. Tout est fait à l'intérieur du même bâtiment où nous sommes aujourd'hui, où nous avons 30 personnes qui travaillent et nous
[SPEAKER_00]: sommes au milieu d'un des plus grands sites de vol dans le monde, à Annecy, où nous vivons, où nous pratiquons. C'était l'idée principale
[SPEAKER_00]: de NEO. Nous l'appelons NEO parce que la principale tendance actuelle pour tous les sports extérieurs est d'aller en Asie et d'importer. avec
[SPEAKER_00]: des conséquences pour la planète. Si vous connaissez le film Matrix, Néo essaie de sortir de la traîne. Nous l'appelons Néo pour sortir de la
[SPEAKER_00]: traîne. Et la deuxième raison pour laquelle on l'appelle Néo, c'est parce que c'est la dernière lettre de l'alphabet Berbère. Cette lettre
[SPEAKER_00]: est le logo de Néo et signifie Freeman. C'est la raison pour laquelle nous appelons la marque Néo, parce que nous faisons des choses dans
[SPEAKER_00]: l'industrie. Thanks for explaining it so well. I think this gives our audience an idea about much more than some of our websites. It's brave to
[SPEAKER_01]: come across as a brand based in Europe and challenge the status quo. We're going to try and do all our manufacturing here and compete with all
[SPEAKER_01]: the big ones who have a fully structured assembly line and the material production outsourced to a much cheaper labor market. Way to go Eric,
[SPEAKER_00]: more poverty. It's a part of the main strategy of NEO. Parce que si vous comparez au Vietnam, par exemple, la plupart des bagpipes sur le marché
[SPEAKER_00]: des sports à l'extérieur sont produites principalement au Vietnam. Les différences en coût de salaire, toutes les charges, y compris entre
[SPEAKER_00]: la France et le Vietnam, sont de 6 fois à 12 fois plus élevées en France. Si nous voulons payer nos filles, nous devons mettre des produits de haute
[SPEAKER_00]: qualité, des matériaux de haute qualité, beaucoup d'innovation pour pouvoir vendre nos produits à 30 à 50 % plus cher. C'est comme
[SPEAKER_00]: l'industrie des produits luxueux. Ils doivent vendre très cher et mettre le meilleur de leur connaissance dans leurs produits pour
[SPEAKER_00]: justifier un prix plus élevé pour payer leur salaire. Nous sommes donc dans la même situation. Pour moi, c'est éthique de produire des
[SPEAKER_00]: produits où nous pratiquons le plus d'activités. Cela ne veut pas dire que nous n'exportons pas aux États-Unis ou en Japon, mais la plupart de
[SPEAKER_00]: nos marchés sont en Allemagne, en France et en Suisse. C'est important pour moi d'être local. L'objectif n'est pas d'avoir une grande
[SPEAKER_00]: fabrique. Nous sommes 30 personnes maintenant, peut-être 35 ou 40. Je ne veux pas grandir en nombre, je veux grandir en qualité et excellence
[SPEAKER_00]: des produits. C'est la philosophie principale de la marque, d'être capable de vendre plus cher pour payer correctement nos employés. Ah,
[SPEAKER_01]: c'est merveilleux de entendre que le capitalisme n'est pas la force à conduire derrière tout ça. Et je pense que ce qui me fait être curieux,
[SPEAKER_01]: c'est que vous avez été dans l'industrie pendant assez longtemps, peut-être 10 ans ou plus ? Oui, 12 ans plus tôt. Le premier arnais
[SPEAKER_00]: s'appelait Paul the String, un arnais montagneux. Oui. Depuis 35 ans. J'ai commencé quand j'avais 17 ans. J'ai été dans l'industrie du
[SPEAKER_00]: paragliding pendant plus de 30 ans. J'ai commencé à l'âge de 19 ans en tant qu'entraîneur. Je suis allé en Corée et j'étais à Edel, le plus
[SPEAKER_00]: grand fabricant dans le monde. J'y étais pendant 5 mois et j'ai rencontré quelqu'un qui était très important dans ma vie. Nous avons
[SPEAKER_00]: essayé de travailler ensemble en 1991. J'ai travaillé pour ITV, une marque locale à Nancy. J'ai ensuite rejoint Gene quand il a créé Gene
[SPEAKER_00]: Gliders en 1998. J'ai toujours travaillé dans la fabrication du paragliding. Edel, ITV, Gin Gliders, Néo, étaient en train de produire
[SPEAKER_00]: localement. Parce que Gin est coréen, en Asie, donc il était en train de produire en Asie. ITVM était en train de produire en France, donc
[SPEAKER_00]: c'était local, dans les années 90. J'ai continué à créer mon propre marque pour être aussi un manufacturier local. Est-ce que vous avez
[SPEAKER_01]: trouvé que c'était difficile d'atteindre le prix ou de satisfaire les ordres, juste en ce qui concerne les chiffres? Parce que les économies
[SPEAKER_01]: de taille sont une grande chose dans l'industrie. Et bien sûr, si vous produisez dans un nombre plus large, dans un endroit où c'est beaucoup
[SPEAKER_01]: plus cher, vous pouvez justifier les chiffres de balance ou l'investissement dans votre projet. Parfois, en restant à ces
[SPEAKER_01]: principes, pour n'importe quel manufacturier, ça n'a pas de sens pour les gens de choisir ce chemin parce que le prix que ça ajoute à votre vie,
[SPEAKER_01]: sauf pour l'argent. Ou est-ce que vous vous êtes confronté à la question que j'aurais pu juste aller mainstream et essayer de compter sur les
[SPEAKER_01]: règles que tout le monde d'autre joue avec plutôt que de me faire ma propre? C'est un silence. Nous devons designer nos produits de la
[SPEAKER_00]: manière dont nous les produirons en France. Nous considérons la distribution et le marketing pour pouvoir être compétitifs. C'est une
[SPEAKER_00]: vraie grande challenge. Nous sommes 12 ans. Au début, nous faisions des arnaques et des ailes pour le speed riding. Maintenant, nous faisons
[SPEAKER_00]: aussi des backpacks pour le mountaineering, le climat. le ski et tous les sports que nous pratiquons nous-mêmes. Le plus facile serait
[SPEAKER_00]: d'aller en Asie pour produire. J'ai créé une fabrique en 2001 en Chine, donc j'étais en train de gérer la production. Ce n'était pas difficile
[SPEAKER_00]: pour moi, j'avais le bon contact, mais je voulais me défendre. Pour se défendre, tu peux faire quelque chose de spécial. Mon objectif n'était
[SPEAKER_00]: pas d'être le plus grand fabricant du monde. Je ne suis pas capable de faire ça. Mon objectif n'était pas d'avoir une grande entreprise. Je
[SPEAKER_00]: n'ai pas besoin de beaucoup d'argent, je veux juste vivre et faire vivre ma famille et mes employés, et la famille de mes employés vivre de cela en
[SPEAKER_00]: faisant des choses que les autres ne font pas. C'est un vrai défi parce que chaque année, c'est difficile de survivre. Nous avons beaucoup
[SPEAKER_00]: investi et nous avons fait le pas par pas. Je ne viens pas d'une famille riche. Chaque année, nous devons acheter une nouvelle machine. Il y a eu
[SPEAKER_00]: beaucoup d'investissements. Maintenant, nous avons environ 43 machines dans la société. Nous avons une machine de serrage laser, une
[SPEAKER_00]: machine pour couper le webbing, de nombreux processus différents pour couper les fabriques. Et étape par étape, nous avons construit cela au
[SPEAKER_00]: cours des 12 dernières années. Et maintenant, nous commençons à être un peu confortables. Nous faisons un petit workshop. Nous avons fait
[SPEAKER_00]: notre propre workshop il y a cinq ans. L'année dernière, nous avons augmenté la taille du double du workshop. Maintenant, nous avons un
[SPEAKER_00]: workshop avec Shisa. 1 000 m2. Chaque mois, chaque semaine, c'est une lutte pour survivre. Parce qu'en France, nous avons plus de taxes, plus
[SPEAKER_00]: de charges sociales, plus d'impôts. C'est nouveau. J'ai eu l'occasion d'avoir une femme qui a vraiment compris mon passion. Parce que
[SPEAKER_00]: parfois, certaines personnes me disent pourquoi tu ne vas pas produire en Asie et avoir beaucoup plus de monnaie. La vie est plus un défi que de
[SPEAKER_00]: donner de la monnaie. What a way to put it across. It's heartening to see a brand like this come out and set their own rules and stick to that. Just
[SPEAKER_01]: out of curiosity, Eric, I want to touch upon manufacturing. Paragliding manufacturing is distributed. It's not centralized. In
[SPEAKER_01]: Europe, you have sky paragliders who make their own thing. And you have aerodynamics in Sri Lanka. So there are multiple factories in
[SPEAKER_01]: different places. Then you see people like you doing your own thing here. Gabriel from Vintech in Spain. So there are European-based small
[SPEAKER_01]: factories. Then there are Asia-based big factories. Qu'est- ce qui se déroule en essayant d'avoir une entreprise comme cette ? La recherche
[SPEAKER_01]: d'investisseurs comme tous les autres grands entreprises ? Ou est-ce plus ou moins comme un petit groupe de amis qui se réunissent et disent «
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, nous avons l'expertise et nous allons mettre de l'argent et le faire ? » Comment l'écoute l'audience ? Il y a trois manières de
[SPEAKER_01]: fabriquer dans le monde. La première est que les grands fabricants ont leur propre marque. Si vous avez beaucoup de marques sur
[SPEAKER_00]: le
[SPEAKER_00]: marché, Ils sont des gens de marketing, des designers, avec des ordinateurs dans leur bureau, et ils ont des certifications, mais ils
[SPEAKER_00]: ne produisent pas. Parfois, ils ne savent même pas comment mettre le fil dans le nid. Et ce genre de marques, pour de grands fabricants, en Sri
[SPEAKER_00]: Lanka, en Chine, en Vietnam, et ces grands fabricants produisent pour de nombreuses petites marques. Généralement, si vous voulez devenir
[SPEAKER_00]: une marque majeure dans le marché du paragliding, des marques comme Jean Glider, comme Skywalk, Ozone, elles ont leur propre les facilités
[SPEAKER_00]: de production en Asie. En produisant dans votre fabrique, vous ne pouvez pas être une marque majeure sur le marché parce que vous devez
[SPEAKER_00]: contrôler la qualité. C'est super important. La qualité et la sécurité des produits. Et pour être capable de faire de l'innovation, vous devez
[SPEAKER_00]: faire vos propres investissements dans votre machine, dans vos gens, pour entraîner vos gens et vous devez avoir votre propre production. La
[SPEAKER_00]: troisième catégorie est une marque comme moi. On considère aussi les petites marques qui essayent de faire de la qualité et de faire beaucoup
[SPEAKER_00]: d'innovation, en faisant des productions locales et en essayant de réussir avec ça. On n'a pas besoin de mélanger des personnes qui ont leur
[SPEAKER_00]: propre production différente des marques qui travaillent avec un propriétaire. Pour moi, c'était juste le début. J'ai eu de
[SPEAKER_00]: l'expérience dans le marché du paragliding et j'étais distributeur pour Gin in France. Et puis, j'ai mis toute la petite monnaie que j'avais
[SPEAKER_00]: pour produire un premier arnais. J'y suis allé en 2010. Et j'étais avec un ami, et ce ami utilisait un harnais de climat. Vous ne pouvez pas
[SPEAKER_00]: ouvrir le harnais. Vous devez le mettre comme un pantalon. Et quand vous êtes à terre, c'est très difficile de le porter. J'utilisais un harnais
[SPEAKER_00]: de boulders en diamant noir pour le climat. Vous pouvez le fermer, et ensuite vous avez les bandes, vous pouvez les fermer avec le
[SPEAKER_00]: paragliding. Et ils créent le harnais de corde, avec les bandes de pied que vous pouvez fermer directement dans le carabinaire. Puis, après
[SPEAKER_00]: que beaucoup d'entreprises ont compris ce concept, j'ai commencé à le vendre pour mes amis. Et ils m'ont demandé pourquoi je n'avais pas créé
[SPEAKER_00]: ma marque. Et puis, l'idée de faire des produits faits en France est arrivée parce qu'il y avait beaucoup d'emplois en France à l'époque. Et
[SPEAKER_00]: je considère qu'il y avait beaucoup de filles qui vendaient des vêtements dans les magasins. Ils n'ont pas eu la possibilité
[SPEAKER_00]: d'utiliser leur connaissance. J'ai décidé de créer l'entreprise. Je n'ai pas reçu beaucoup d'argent. On a fait le pas à pas. J'ai reçu 30
[SPEAKER_00]: personnes. Certains amis sont venus avec un peu d'argent pour m'aider un peu. Mais on n'a jamais mis de grands investisseurs dans
[SPEAKER_00]: l'entreprise. Wow, c'est ce que sont les projets passionnés. Tu as la motivation et l'univers s'en sort. Je aime ton honnêteté, Eric. What
[SPEAKER_01]: does it take to start a brand? Do you have a certain bit of orders for the wings that you can say, all right, I'm selling 10 wings or 20 wings a year,
[SPEAKER_01]: so I can go to this factory and say, take my money, take my design and give me the raw material? Or do you start with whatever you have, especially
[SPEAKER_01]: in your case? Or do you go with big brands or big investors? If somebody wants to get into this business, what is the way for them to get started in
[SPEAKER_01]: this direction? La première chose, c'est de voler et aimer voler. Si vous voulez faire des produits en paragliding, vous devez voler et
[SPEAKER_00]: aimer voler. J'ai un ami qui a une fabrique de ski juste à 200 mètres de ma fabrique. Et il est championne olympique de ski. Il aime skier et fait
[SPEAKER_00]: son propre ski maintenant. Je ne suis pas un champion du monde en paragliding, mais j'ai volé depuis longtemps. Ma passion, c'est que
[SPEAKER_00]: vous devez avoir des idées pour créer une bonne sensibilité dans l'air. J'ai appris ce genre. C'est sensible dans l'air d'être capable de
[SPEAKER_00]: trimer correctement l'armoire. J'ai quelques amis et la machine de sauvetage a commencé. Une autre possibilité, c'est que certaines
[SPEAKER_00]: marques, autour d'elles, trouvent de l'argent. On commence avec un grand investissement dans le marketing et le design. Si c'est un
[SPEAKER_00]: succès, à l'origine, généralement, ils ont créé une grande fabrique en Asie. Si c'est un succès, ils doivent créer leur propre fabrique si ils
[SPEAKER_00]: veulent devenir une marque majeure. Ça dépend de ce que vous voulez dans la vie. La première chose, c'est d'avoir la passion pour jouer. C'est le
[SPEAKER_00]: plus important. Il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont venus dans le paragliding pour s'amuser, ou parce qu'ils pensaient que ça serait un
[SPEAKER_00]: gros business. Ce n'est pas un gros business. Si tu n'as pas de passion pour le vol, c'est difficile. Pourquoi certaines marques manquent
[SPEAKER_01]: après une période de temps ? Parce que j'ai vu que c'est un marché très niché, où tu essaies de targeter un nombre très sélectionné, un nombre
[SPEAKER_01]: limité de personnes. Mais certaines marques comme LL, comme tu l'as dit, Massive, qui a le marché, qui a le flux d'argent, qui a déjà fait la
[SPEAKER_01]: ligne de produit, qui s'éloigne, qui sort. Et certaines autres marques comme, disons, Axios était assez grande. Je ne peux pas continuer à
[SPEAKER_01]: prendre des noms, mais beaucoup de fois, je vois que les marques ont leur courbe supérieure, comme quand le propriétaire principal était
[SPEAKER_01]: vraiment passionné de ça, et la marque a reçu très bien, et puis ça commence à descendre. Est-ce que c'est parce que ces entreprises sont
[SPEAKER_01]: passionnées et ne sont pas organisées d'une manière professionnelle ? Quelle est exactement la raison pour laquelle nous voyons des marques
[SPEAKER_01]: venir et aller et que très peu restent pendant longtemps ? Comme je l'ai dit, c'est principalement basé sur la passion. Comparé à d'autres
[SPEAKER_00]: entreprises, quand ce n'est pas basé sur la passion, on peut le vendre et trouver des professionnels pour continuer la histoire. Le bonheur
[SPEAKER_00]: dans le monde est principalement un processus humain avec un homme ou plusieurs femmes. Parfois, elles peuvent être moins innovantes.
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est la vie. On n'est pas toujours au top. Le champion du monde n'est pas le champion du monde pendant 30 ans. Le plus difficile pour une marque de
[SPEAKER_00]: leader est de ne pas devenir la première sur le marché, de rester là. Et derrière les marques de paragliding, vous avez des hommes très
[SPEAKER_00]: importants Il y en a quelques-uns. Je dirais que je connais très bien Gene. Gene est un designer fantastique. Il est une personne
[SPEAKER_00]: fantastique. Il était au top et il est toujours dans les marques principales, mais il était le numéro un. Pour rester, c'est super
[SPEAKER_00]: difficile parce que les compétiteurs essayent de gagner. Dans le paragliding, c'est une question de passion. Il n'y a pas beaucoup de
[SPEAKER_00]: gens dans le monde qui sont passionnés par le paragliding. Donc, vous devez trouver ça. Et probablement, Les gens qui ont le passion, je sais
[SPEAKER_00]: que Gene n'est pas le meilleur gars dans le business. Il est un super designer, mais il n'est pas le meilleur gars dans le business. Donc,
[SPEAKER_00]: c'est difficile d'être stable. Et la deuxième raison est probablement que les gens dans le paragliding pensent trop beaucoup sur le produit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ils disent toujours que si je lance un 2-liner ENC, ou si je lance ce arme, ou si je lance ça, l'année prochaine sera bonne. Donc, ils pensent
[SPEAKER_00]: beaucoup sur le produit. Et ils ne pensent pas assez à la marque. Et le meilleur exemple, et probablement l'un des meilleurs succès dans le
[SPEAKER_00]: marché du paragliding, c'est Advance. Advance a lancé un ANC, et Advance est la marque la plus stable dans les 20 dernières années dans
[SPEAKER_00]: l'industrie, parce que c'est la valeur de la marque. C'est une question de business et de vision que vous avez pour votre entreprise. Nous avons
[SPEAKER_00]: des gens qui sont créatifs, passionnés par le paragliding. C'est une histoire merveilleuse. Nous sommes nés il y a 100 ans, nous volons.
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est magique, nous sommes super heureux. Ces gens ont une passion. J'ai rencontré beaucoup de designers dans ma vie de paraglider, il y a 20
[SPEAKER_00]: ans. Et puis, ils ont tous une passion, probablement moins business way. Et les gars qui ont un bon business way, ils ont moins de passion.
[SPEAKER_00]: Donc, ce n'est pas le business où vous allez gagner le plus d'argent. Je dirais que la vie est comme ça, finalement. C'est une chose que j'ai
[SPEAKER_01]: souvent vu avec beaucoup de gens créatifs, disons des artistes, des musiciens, beaucoup d'entre eux, qui essayent de mettre leur cœur et
[SPEAKER_01]: leur âme dans ce qu'ils font, sont le moins inquiets en essayant d'avoir un plan de marketing structuré ou d'arriver avec un jeu commercial où
[SPEAKER_01]: ils peuvent gagner de l'argent. Ce que je me demandais, Eric, quand un nouveau consommateur, disons quelqu'un qui s'intéresse à
[SPEAKER_01]: Paragliding, ou quelqu'un qui a été là pour quelques années pour connaître les marques et toutes leurs technologies et tout ce qui est
[SPEAKER_01]: derrière, investir de l'argent n'est pas facile, parce que Paragliding n'est pas le plus cher. Il te requiert de sortir avec au
[SPEAKER_01]: moins 2-3 000 minimum si tu veux acheter un kit pré-acheté, ou au moins 4-5 000 minimum si tu veux un bon niveau de performance brand new.
[SPEAKER_01]: Choisir une marque est une choix personnelle. Est-ce que vous avez une idée de comment les gens peuvent prioriser leur choix de marque ? Le
[SPEAKER_01]: facteur de la légitimité aide, mais la légitimité construit une histoire. Voyant le déclin d'une marque à l'arrière, elle ne sera pas si
[SPEAKER_01]: visible. Disons que si une marque a été innovante pendant 20 ans et qu'elle n'est plus innovante pendant les 5 derniers ans, vous pouvez
[SPEAKER_01]: toujours sortir et donner de l'argent et investir dans quelque chose qui n'est pas si significatif. Quand il s'agit de la décision de faire
[SPEAKER_01]: comme un client, qu'est-ce que les gens devraient vraiment faire pour dépenser leur argent le plus efficacement possible dans cette
[SPEAKER_01]: industrie ? Je pense que le paragliding est cher. Si vous volez avec un aéroport, c'est plus cher. Il y a d'autres sports qui sont plus coûteux
[SPEAKER_00]: que le paragliding. Finalement, le ski est aussi cher. Si vous n'allez pas en tournée de ski et que vous achetez votre pass de ski tous les jours,
[SPEAKER_00]: c'est aussi cher. Mais le paragliding est cher. Je conseillerais aux débutants de ne pas choisir la marque la plus chère. Parce que s'ils sont
[SPEAKER_00]: chers, il y a des raisons. Avec la marque la plus haute, avec le prix la plus haut, vous avez un second marché. Par exemple, si vous prenez notre
[SPEAKER_00]: harnais de pod pour un harnais légère, c'est un harnais que Max Pinot et Tim Allongy ont utilisé dans les dernières salles Red Bull. Cet harnais
[SPEAKER_00]: est l'un des harnais de pod le plus cher. Mais après trois ou quatre ans d'utilisation, vous pouvez encore le vendre à 900 ou à 1 000 euros sur le
[SPEAKER_00]: marché secondaire facilement. Cela signifie que le harness coûte 2 000 euros au début, mais après trois ou quatre ans, vous pouvez le vendre à 60
[SPEAKER_00]: % du prix. Mais si vous prenez un harness qui est très fragile, avec une marque chère, il va aller au boulot. En fait, le monnaie que vous
[SPEAKER_00]: investissez, vous perdrez tout. Peut-être que vous le vendrez à 1 500 ou 1 300 euros. Mais finalement, vous ne pouvez pas le reseller. Avec des
[SPEAKER_00]: marques hautes, vous pouvez le vendre en seconde main. Donc, c'est parfois mieux d'acheter une marque haute que d'acheter une nouvelle,
[SPEAKER_00]: une marque chère qui ne peut pas être vendue. C'est la première chose. La deuxième chose, c'est d'aller à des vendeurs professionnels et leur
[SPEAKER_00]: dire « Je veux voler cette arnaque, je veux voler cette arnaque. » Et si vous vous sentez bien avec votre arnaque ou votre arnaque, vous pouvez
[SPEAKER_00]: l'acheter. Essayez des équipements, essayez différentes choses et parlez avec d'autres personnes. Soyez prudents avec les forums, il y a
[SPEAKER_00]: des bêtises sur les forums. Mais allez voir des professeurs, des instructeurs, discutez avec eux, et voyez sur les montagnes certains
[SPEAKER_00]: gars utilisant des arnaques ou des ailes que vous aimeriez voler. Et testez-vous-même. Même les débutants peuvent tester eux-mêmes. Ils
[SPEAKER_00]: peuvent tester les ailes des débutants et dire « je préfère celle-là ». Si vous êtes sensitif, essayez de voir qui est derrière l'entreprise,
[SPEAKER_00]: comment l'entreprise produit, si c'est leur propre fabrique, et essayez d'entendre ça. Mais n'y allez pas de la manière la plus chère,
[SPEAKER_00]: c'est sûr. Surtout avec le parachute d'escalier. Et par exemple, je suis désigneur d'escaliers. Vous pouvez voir que si vous volez avec
[SPEAKER_00]: différents types d'escaliers, vous avez beaucoup de différentes stabilités, différentes géométries. L'escalier n'est pas seulement
[SPEAKER_00]: un ferryman. C'est une géométrie de confort, de stabilité et de performance. Donc, quand vous allez essayer quelques différents
[SPEAKER_00]: types d'escaliers, vous verrez que parfois vous pouvez avoir... une armature instable qui n'est pas capable de tourner bien et vous pouvez
[SPEAKER_01]: avoir une armature stable qui est capable de tourner très bien donc essayez et testez votre équipement que vous voulez acheter j'adore la
[SPEAKER_01]: façon dont vous le mettez c'est votre but tout le monde qui veut réécouter ce qu'ils ont dit juste appuyez sur le bouton rewind sur
[SPEAKER_01]: spotify ou où que vous ayez votre podcast c'était pure magie ou conseils sur comment le acheter mais Eric vous avez mentionné de ne pas acheter un
[SPEAKER_01]: parachute de réserve substandard Disons que le Round Reserve ou le Rogalo ont un design très standard qui est resté le même pendant des
[SPEAKER_01]: années et ils ne nécessitent pas vraiment d'expertise spécifique en les collant ensemble ou d'autres matériaux spécifiques. Alors
[SPEAKER_01]: pourquoi ne pas aller pour le Reserve le plus cher, comme quelqu'un qui était Merging economies of scale, buying the raw material in a lot more
[SPEAKER_01]: quantity and has set guidelines and a set standard for manufacturing. Where will that make a difference? I go to talk with the SIV instructors,
[SPEAKER_00]: they will tell you that there are some rescues which are really good and some rescues which are really bad. It's not a matter of manufacturing,
[SPEAKER_00]: it's also a matter of design. Il y a eu un rescue de géométrie Apex dans le passé, et maintenant on a un rescue de planar square. Il s'agit de savoir
[SPEAKER_00]: qui sera le plus rapide, quel sera l'endroit, quelle sera la longueur de poids, quel sera l'objectif principal d'un rescue, le temps
[SPEAKER_00]: d'ouverture, le rythme de synchro, la stabilité. Comment vous vous connectez à l'armée, l'effet de l'œil, la position quand vous landez,
[SPEAKER_00]: il y a beaucoup de choses à faire avec ça. L'escalier n'est pas seulement un escalier, c'est aussi une armée. Certains escaliers sont vraiment
[SPEAKER_00]: bons et d'autres ne sont pas bons. Ce que je vois dans le marché, et quand je discute avec les instructeurs, les adhérents, et les marques les
[SPEAKER_00]: plus célèbres, pas seulement les marques les plus célèbres, généralement ont le meilleur escalier. Je n'y crois pas vraiment. Tu
[SPEAKER_00]: peux aller à une fabrique et acheter un Rescue et mettre ton sticker dessus, ton logo dessus. Mais je n'y crois pas vraiment. Je préfère
[SPEAKER_00]: aller à un manufacturier et développer sa propre façon. Parce que le design d'un produit n'est pas seulement de dire que je le design et le
[SPEAKER_00]: vendre. C'est aussi ce que je veux faire avec le produit. Qui va utiliser mon produit ? Quelle façon va-t-il l'utiliser ? Où va-t-il voler ?
[SPEAKER_00]: Toutes ces choses. Et j'ai préféré aller à un fabricant qui dit, nous avons fait ce produit de cette façon, plutôt que d'aller à un fabricant
[SPEAKER_00]: qui achète un rescue qui est déjà designé. L'élastique, c'est vrai ? 1970,
[SPEAKER_01]: ça ne change pas. Donc, si vous devez le fabriquer selon certaines guidelines, ça devrait être la longueur de l'épaisseur, c'est comme ça
[SPEAKER_01]: que les risers devraient ressembler, c'est comme ça que les lignes devraient être fortes. Pouvez-vous encore avoir des
[SPEAKER_01]: caractéristiques différentes en fonction de ce que vous avez fabriqué dans une fabrique différente ? un nom de marque différent au-dessus de
[SPEAKER_01]: ça. Quand le design est si standardisé, comment peut la qualité être différente ? Le marché change. Il y a 20 ans, on volait avec Rescue, qui
[SPEAKER_00]: était libre. Maintenant, on volait avec Rescue, qui est entre 1,5 kg et 2 kg. Pour obtenir ce résultat, nous devons changer les matériaux. Par
[SPEAKER_00]: exemple, nous avons utilisé des lignes polyester pendant longtemps. Maintenant, nous utilisons des lignes dynamo, la plupart du temps. La
[SPEAKER_00]: fabrication doit être plus saine et plus légère. Le test de charge est toujours le même. Dans la certification LASTIEN, vous allez utiliser
[SPEAKER_00]: différents matériaux. C'est comme un paraglider. Vous ne prenez pas un design standard et vous changez juste le matériau. Quand vous changez
[SPEAKER_00]: le matériau, vous devez adapter le design. C'est la première chose. Je ne suis pas spécialiste avec Rogalo. Je préfère Square Rescue ou Round
[SPEAKER_00]: Rescue. Même avec Square Rescue, vous pouvez avoir différents morceaux, formes, trimer vos lignes Apex. Vous pouvez les plier d'une
[SPEAKER_00]: manière différente. Le petit triment fait la tension dans les panneaux, différentes lignes, beaucoup de choses. C'est une bonne
[SPEAKER_00]: équipe de R&D, un bon designer, plusieurs designers, un bon pilote de tests et assez d'argent et de pouvoir pour développer ça. C'est une
[SPEAKER_00]: marque comme Néo. Nous ne faisons pas de rescue et nous ne faisons pas de wings. D'abord, ce ne sera pas profitable de produire en France. Nous
[SPEAKER_00]: faisons juste du rucksack et du harness. C'est un travail énorme de développement. Nous sommes cinq personnes en R&D à Néo. It's a big
[SPEAKER_00]: investment of development. Some brands pick one rescue, one manufacturer, one wing, one harness. They don't do specific design
[SPEAKER_00]: work. They just change colors, the pocket here and the piece system here. But generally, the concept is not water pipe, pocket and piece
[SPEAKER_00]: system. It's design, aerodynamic. It's a basement with geometry. It's a base harness for comfort, webbings and buckles to be strong enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is a basement of. And like I tell you since the beginning of de cette conversation. Généralement, vous avez besoin d'un R&D pour faire un
[SPEAKER_00]: travail propre. Et même dans les rescues, ce n'est pas complètement standard. Je ne suis pas spécialiste avec le rogalo, mais je pense que le
[SPEAKER_00]: rogalo n'est pas complètement standard. Quand vous venez d'une rescue normale de rogalo à un light one, vous avez besoin d'adapter les choses.
[SPEAKER_01]: C'est très intéressant. J'adore la façon dont vous l'expliquez. Nous devrions enfoncer la sélection de la pièce plutôt que de se fixer sur le
[SPEAKER_01]: marketing. En parlant de produits, Eric, je vois que l'inventaire de NEO a grandit beaucoup. J'ai suivi votre site pour quelques années.
[SPEAKER_01]: Vous aviez beaucoup aimé le speed riding Wings au début. Maintenant, quand je regarde votre range de produits, vous avez la
[SPEAKER_01]: diversification, les harnais, les paquets, les protecteurs et les accessoires. Comment avez-vous décidé de diversifier ? Quelle a été la
[SPEAKER_01]: décision que vous avez faite quand vous avez commencé à introduire plus d'innovation et de produits dans votre inventaire ? Quel a été le
[SPEAKER_01]: processus de pensée derrière cela ? On dirait que nous avons diversifié, mais en fait nous n'avons pas diversifié. C'est très
[SPEAKER_00]: simple. Nous sommes des craftsmen, donc nous utilisons nos mains et nos machines pour fabriquer des produits. Notre spécialité est de
[SPEAKER_00]: produire avec de la fabrique saine et très sèche. Paragliding harness, vous devez serrer très sèche, webbing et matériaux. C'est notre
[SPEAKER_00]: spécialité. Quand nous fabriquons des harness et des backpacks, vous avez besoin d'être capable de serrer saine et sèche. Nous sommes
[SPEAKER_00]: spécialisés dans ce domaine. Nous sommes les seuls workshops en France capables de faire cela. Nous avons donc décidé de ne pas faire des
[SPEAKER_00]: paragliders ou des parachutes d'escalade parce que ce n'est pas où nous sommes les meilleurs. Nous n'avons pas diversifié beaucoup. Nous
[SPEAKER_00]: sommes revenus pour faire ce que nous sommes les meilleurs et ce que nous pouvons faire avec nos machines et nos mains. C'est le seul produit que
[SPEAKER_01]: nous ne manufacturons pas nous-mêmes.
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est le seul produit de la gamme Néo que nous ne fabriquons pas en France. Techniquement, c'est difficile de trouver en France un
[SPEAKER_00]: fabricant capable de faire une telle chaussure. Nous avons trouvé un très bon fabricant, un très technique, avec lequel nous avons une bonne
[SPEAKER_00]: relation et nous pouvons travailler. Ma expérience est bonne en textile. manufacturing and backpacks i'm not the specialist of
[SPEAKER_00]: helmets there was a lack of on the market of a good helmet there was a lot of brands coming in and out of the market it was difficult for the dealer to
[SPEAKER_00]: have something stable so we just decided to make one helmet for paragliding and also certified for ski climbing and ski touring in
[SPEAKER_00]: partnership with this manufacturer abs shell to be strong Nous n'avons pas trouvé le bon fabricant, donc nous avons trouvé un partenaire
[SPEAKER_00]: technique capable de le faire. Nous avons travaillé deux ans sur le développement et maintenant nous le vendons. Nous avons quelques
[SPEAKER_00]: projets de paragliding et de mates dans le futur. Ce sera un autre modèle, mais nous ne sommes pas devenus un fabricant de paragliding et
[SPEAKER_00]: je ne vais pas installer une fabrique en France pour la fabrication parce que je ne suis pas spécialiste. J'adore votre take sur ça. C'est
[SPEAKER_01]: bien de voir quelqu'un dire que l'argent n'est pas une priorité, mais qu'il ajoute de la valeur à son marque et à la vie des gens. En parlant de
[SPEAKER_01]: collaboration, une chose que je suis sûr que pas seulement moi, mais beaucoup de gens dans la communauté ont été curieux, c'est Choreo.
[SPEAKER_01]: Parce que j'ai lu sur votre page web que vous et Choreo vont beaucoup plus loin. Vous avez travaillé avec eux depuis 2014. Vous êtes retourné en
[SPEAKER_01]: force sur cette nouvelle technologie révolutionnaire qui a été adaptée avec Jin et quelques autres marques. Parlons de Choreo et de
[SPEAKER_01]: vous et de cette protection qui est prometteuse, mais questionnée dans l'industrie. Quand j'ai commencé à développer mon arnaque, je pensais
[SPEAKER_00]: à la protection. La protection n'est pas difficile à ingénier, mais à fabriquer en France, ce n'est pas facile, à cause des coûts de travail.
[SPEAKER_00]: Puis, j'ai commencé à penser à quelque chose d'inflatable, à différentes choses. Un gars très important à Néo est venu dans
[SPEAKER_00]: l'entreprise. Il avait 20 ans et c'était Mathias, qui travaille toujours avec moi. Il est le chef de production à Néo et le designer avec
[SPEAKER_00]: moi dans l'entreprise.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mathias est venu avec cette idée. Il a travaillé à l'école de développement des produits sportifs. Il est venu et m'a dit « Regarde,
[SPEAKER_00]: il y a un Choroïd, pourquoi ne pas aller chez eux ? » Donc, avec Mathias, nous sommes allés voir Choroïd. Ils étaient intéressés par notre
[SPEAKER_00]: position. Nous étions déjà innovants en termes de géométrie de l'armée et de paragliding, de speed riding. Ils ont dit « Oui, nous ne voulons pas
[SPEAKER_00]: travailler avec la plus grande marque, mais nous voulons travailler avec une marque qui est proche, innovante et qui a une bonne image. » Puis
[SPEAKER_00]: ils ont commencé à travailler avec nous. Nous avons fait un contrat exclusif pour le marché du paragliding mondial. Il a fallu trois ans
[SPEAKER_00]: pour lancer la première protection de colloïdes. C'était beaucoup de temps. Mathias est devenu employé de la compagnie et maintenant il gère
[SPEAKER_00]: la compagnie avec moi. Deuxièmement, nous avons développé une nouvelle génération. L'année prochaine, nous lancerons une nouvelle
[SPEAKER_00]: génération de colloïdes, qui sont plus flexibles, avec une éponge et une forme ronde pour s'adapter aux nouvelles armes aérodynamiques. Ce
[SPEAKER_00]: qui était intéressant pour Mathias et moi au début, c'est la façon dont les colloïdes absorbent l'impact. Toutes les protections que nous
[SPEAKER_00]: avions pendant longtemps, comme le paragliding, la mousse, l'airbag ou le rebond, l'énergie retourne à votre visage. Quand vous tombez,
[SPEAKER_00]: comme dans un voiture, les deux structures se déforment et s'absorbent par le bruit, l'humidité et la destruction du matériel, alors cette
[SPEAKER_00]: énergie n'est pas un rebond. avec des matériaux qui sont élastiques. La mousse est élastique, l'air est élastique, les pièces en plastique ou
[SPEAKER_00]: en 3D sont élastiques, les tubes polymères qui s'éclatent, et ça élimine l'énergie. Et c'était la chose principale qui était vraiment
[SPEAKER_00]: intéressante. C'était intéressant parce que c'est plus sain, perlite, et c'est plus compact, seulement 7 ou 8 cm. C'est ainsi que nous
[SPEAKER_00]: commençons à travailler avec Choroïd. Nous avons des ingénieurs et nous commençons à travailler en collaboration. Ce que j'aime, c'est
[SPEAKER_00]: qu'ils sont une grande entreprise, mais ils continuent d'être fidèles à nous. Nous continuons de nous innover et c'est vraiment bien. Je
[SPEAKER_01]: voudrais parler un peu de la fonction de Choroïd, parce qu'il y a eu quelques crashs. Je suis sûr que beaucoup de gens l'ont vu dans Faraday.
[SPEAKER_01]: Vous avez vu les blocs de Choroïd Protector, les blocs verts tournés sur l'impact. Qu'est-ce qui les cause de changer de place et de rester
[SPEAKER_01]: rigides et de ne pas vraiment avoir le crash à l'aise ou à l'absorption ? Comment est-ce que ça se fait ? Disons que nous regardons un protécteur
[SPEAKER_01]: dans le courtyard où ces blocs sont inclus avec du plâtre ou d'autres matériaux pour les garder en place. Sur l'impact, nous avons vu par des
[SPEAKER_01]: photographes qui ont été partagés en ligne que les blocs se tordent en place au lieu de crumpler. Je me demande ce qu'il s'agit de cela. Est-ce
[SPEAKER_01]: que cela a été résolu ? Comment est-ce que cela est regardé d'un point de vue manufacturier ? La première chose que nous avons pensé lors du
[SPEAKER_00]: développement était de mettre un bloc entier de coroïdes. Mais ce n'était pas bon en termes d'impact. Pour avoir une bonne absorption
[SPEAKER_00]: d'impact, vous devriez mettre 78 coroïdes. Si vous avez beaucoup de coroïdes, en fait, vous n'arrêtez que 10 ou 20%. L'absorption de
[SPEAKER_00]: l'impact n'était pas suffisante. Nous avons décidé d'utiliser des blocs de coroïdes. Mais vous avez raison, nous devons garder les
[SPEAKER_00]: coroïdes verticales autant que possible quand nous brûlons. C'était un long test, trois ans de test, pour trouver le bon mousse, le bon
[SPEAKER_00]: matériau, et le bon sable pour adapter les certifications. Quand vous brûlez, les coroïdes ne se tournent pas vers le côté. Il y a toujours une
[SPEAKER_00]: absorption d'impact. Mais vous devez trouver le bon équilibre entre le coroïde et la sponge. Si vous avez trop de sponges, Ce n'est pas
[SPEAKER_00]: nécessaire. C'était un grand délai de trouver la meilleure façon. À chaque étape, nous avons changé le pourcentage de protection des
[SPEAKER_00]: choroïdes. Ça dépend si c'est une protection longue ou courte. Nous comprenons plus sur les choroïdes et nous avons trouvé que mettre une
[SPEAKER_00]: forme ronde sous la protection donne un meilleur résultat si vous ne criez pas exactement verticalement, si vous criez de l'autre côté. À
[SPEAKER_00]: chaque étape, nous améliorons cette technologie. Je suis juste curieux. Ce n'était pas comme ça au début. Disons que cela se passe avec
[SPEAKER_01]: toute une nouvelle technologie. Quand vous sortez avec une nouvelle technologie, elle a ses propres applications laboratoires, où vous
[SPEAKER_01]: apprenez certaines dynamiques. Et puis, elle a ses propres applications dans le monde réel, où c'est un tout autre produit. Il y a eu
[SPEAKER_01]: un moment dans la communauté de Paragliding où CoreoHead était questionnée pour ne pas absorber les impacts de côté et où les blocs de
[SPEAKER_01]: CoreoHead étaient en train de se tourner et de les rendre, je ne dirais pas plus dangereux, mais au moins ils ne servaient pas le but dans les
[SPEAKER_01]: crushes. Est-ce que la technologie Corio a atteint un point où elle absorbe l'impact de toutes les directions ? Ou est-ce que le R&D est
[SPEAKER_01]: encore en cours, où le foam et d'autres technologies sont encore plus capables ? L'impact sur l'aéronautique paragliding n'est pas
[SPEAKER_00]: seulement concerné par les coroïdes. On ne peut pas mettre des coroïdes, des mousses ou de l'air tout autour de nous. Il y a une
[SPEAKER_00]: limitation de l'angle d'attaque. Il y a une façon de la limiter. Le problème avec les coroïdes, c'est que vous pouvez voir ce qui se passe
[SPEAKER_00]: quand vous crashez. Toutes les autres protections, tu ne peux pas les voir. Tu ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé quand tu as crashé. La plupart des
[SPEAKER_00]: fois, l'airbag s'en va et ce n'est pas efficace du tout. Mais tu ne peux pas le voir avec tes yeux après. Avec un mousse, tu ne peux pas voir si le
[SPEAKER_00]: mousse était bon ou non. Avec un airbag, tu ne peux pas le voir. Mais avec un collier, tu peux voir ce qui s'est passé. Et puis les gens peuvent en
[SPEAKER_00]: parler. Mais avec les autres protections, ils ne parlent pas parce qu'il n'y a pas de preuve. Certains diront que c'est facile pour Eric de
[SPEAKER_00]: dire ça, mais depuis qu'on a commencé à parler il y a 30 ou 40 minutes, je suis transparent, je ne suis pas un gars qui dit des bêtises. C'est juste
[SPEAKER_00]: le fait que les gens peuvent parler parce qu'ils peuvent voir. Il y a eu certains gars qui ont dit que leur colloïde n'a pas fonctionné parce
[SPEAKER_00]: qu'il n'a pas crashé. Et puis on a reçu des vidéos et le gars n'a pas tombé sur le colloïde. Il est tombé sur ses pieds. Ça fait sens. Mais s'il
[SPEAKER_00]: tombait avec un mousse... Qu'est-ce que c'est un mousse ? Avec une épaule, avec un... Une épaule. Une épaule, oui. Un protecteur de forme.
[SPEAKER_00]: Si il tombait, il ne pouvait pas le voir parce que les effets resteront les mêmes, sauf s'il y a un énorme impact sur l'exposition. Mais avec un
[SPEAKER_00]: coroïde, il dit « Ah, mon coroïde n'a pas brûlé, donc ça n'a pas fonctionné, tu n'as pas tombé sur le coroïde ». Certains disent « Ah, ça
[SPEAKER_00]: n'a pas fonctionné, ça n'a pas fonctionné, tu as tombé trop sur le côté, mais un autre protecteur ne va pas te protéger ». Ce n'est pas un problème
[SPEAKER_00]: de technologie ou de sécurité, c'est un problème de perception des gens. Sur le collier, ils peuvent dire qu'il fonctionne, mais sur un sac
[SPEAKER_00]: à air ou un autre protecteur, ils n'ont pas de problème. Je suis juste curieux, quand il s'agit de la tournure des blocs, est-ce que ça a une
[SPEAKER_01]: explication ? Pourquoi les blocs sortent de leur endroit et sont tournés dans la forme où ils étaient ? Comment ça s'est passé et comment
[SPEAKER_01]: avez-vous réglé ? D'abord, nous avons beaucoup amélioré ce problème. Et maintenant, sur la grande protection, nous allons mettre un mousse
[SPEAKER_00]: sous une éponge très douce, ce qui aidera aussi à éviter la tournure. Pour sûr, si vous êtes vraiment sur le côté, mais c'est la même chose avec
[SPEAKER_00]: n'importe quelle protection, toute la masse d'air, la masse de l'épaule, ou n'importe quoi, va s'éloigner. Nous avons fait l'analyse
[SPEAKER_00]: pour la certification EN, 50 kg, 163 cm, descendre avec une certaine vitesse.
[SPEAKER_00]: Et ce que nous disons aux gens, c'est que quand vous voyez que la couche autour de vos couloirs commence à se briser après l'impact, vous devez
[SPEAKER_00]: changer votre protection, comme votre chapeau quand vous tombez dans un ski ou autre chose. C'est le même principe. Mais nous essayons
[SPEAKER_00]: d'améliorer cela. Mais généralement, ce que nous recevons quand les gens s'arrêtent, quand ils nous envoient leurs couloirs, la plupart du
[SPEAKER_00]: temps, Il y a une partie qui est crashée, parfois à 100%, parfois à 80%, mais il y a toujours une partie qui est crashée. Donc c'est juste comme un
[SPEAKER_01]: casque. Vous devez essayer de le faire. Mais quand je vois que vous êtes en train de fuser des matériaux, d'apporter de nouvelles technologies
[SPEAKER_01]: et d'embrasser les plus anciens et d'essayer de les rendre un peu plus solides. Je voudrais parler de ce nouveau protecteur que Nivea a lancé
[SPEAKER_01]: parce que ça m'est juste venu dans la curiosité. Leurs designers étaient sur le défilé aussi et ils ont parlé d'Orikami. Oricami et Coreo
[SPEAKER_01]: seem similar. Lightweight, impact protection, streamlined, reducing drag. With Coreo's impact protection and Oricami's
[SPEAKER_01]: flexibility, are we looking at combining these technologies? Do you see these both revolutionized technologies working together in time
[SPEAKER_01]: to come? Il y a quelques années, nous avons essayé de développer quelque chose comme Oricami. Et Oricami est complètement différent de Coroid.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ça ressemble, mais c'est différent. Nous avons essayé le 3D. Et la première chose, c'est que Oricami ne crache pas. L'Orikami est
[SPEAKER_00]: élastique. Lorsque vous bougez, comme je l'expliquais auparavant, ce que je sais de l'Orikami, c'est qu'il revient à sa forme originale. Cela
[SPEAKER_00]: signifie que c'est comme une éponge, comme de l'air. C'est élastique, donc vous avez un rebond. Je ne comprends pas vraiment comment il peut
[SPEAKER_00]: absorber l'énergie comme le Chloride. La deuxième chose, c'est que l'Orikami est presque double en poids. que le choroïde. Pour la même
[SPEAKER_00]: épaisseur de protection, le choroïde aurique est de 300 à 400 grammes et le choroïde aurique 800 grammes. C'est assez difficile de comparer.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pour moi, c'est un concept différent. Et la façon dont le choroïde fonctionne, c'est parce qu'il crache. Et c'est important. La façon
[SPEAKER_00]: similaire, c'est qu'en termes de séquence, pour sûr, nous réduisons la séquence et nous réduisons la drogue. C'est quelque chose que nous
[SPEAKER_00]: faisons depuis longtemps au Néo, et c'est pourquoi les glideurs de génie utilisent l'automobile pour le Genie Race 4 et le Genie Race 5.
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est aussi pourquoi l'Ozone utilise l'automobile pour les submarines. C'est aussi pourquoi nous utilisons l'automobile pour
[SPEAKER_00]: les pilotes de l'X-Alps. C'était pour réduire le drag. Parce que c'est bien de mettre un long ferry, mais si tu réduis le drag, c'est aussi
[SPEAKER_00]: mieux. C'est certain que c'est le même résultat entre Orikami et Corinne. En termes d'impact, nous avons un meilleur impact parce que
[SPEAKER_00]: nous sommes autour de 30, sans rescues, entre 30, 31, 32G, 35 maximum, mais ils sont plus proches de 45 ou 50. Donc je n'ai rien contre Orikami,
[SPEAKER_01]: mais vous me posez la question et je... Non, j'adore votre honnêteté, Eric, et s'il vous plaît, n'oubliez pas de parler de la vérité, comme
[SPEAKER_01]: l'industrie et l'audience adorent écouter des gens comme vous, donc... Yeah, as I said in the beginning of the show, more power to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Love the way you bring out these things. As we're reaching the end of the show, I want to touch upon reducing drag before we run out of time here.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you go all this time, why we have seen that, all right, prone position is, I don't know. Je ne sais pas si c'est appelé position prône,
[SPEAKER_01]: mais la position à la place est mieux que la position à la place dans les couches. Et nous essayons de faire autant de réduction de poids que
[SPEAKER_01]: possible. Mais ensuite, je vois quelque chose de plus grand que les submarines qui entrent dans le marché et qui prennent complètement la
[SPEAKER_01]: place, en gardant les choses plus petites et plus fines. Parce que les submarines sont un grand casque autour d'eux. Et la taille de la couche
[SPEAKER_01]: est substantiellement plus grande que n'importe quelle autre couche que nous avons vu dans le marché. Par exemple, le XR7 ou le Genie Race 5 ou
[SPEAKER_01]: 4, les portes-harnais qui existaient, même des fabricants français, même les plus grands, étaient tout à fait très fin, une seule structure,
[SPEAKER_01]: une porte-harnais avec un fer. Mais Submarine vient et développe toute une structure inflatable qui est plus grande en surface. Donc, quand
[SPEAKER_01]: nous avons une zone de surface qui n'est pas un problème pour la drague, pourquoi ne pas ajouter des protecteurs plus élevés autour de nous dans
[SPEAKER_01]: ces portes que nous commençons à voler maintenant pour les rendre encore plus sécurisées ? Pourquoi est-ce que la pensée ou le R&D ne vont
[SPEAKER_01]: pas dans cette direction ? C'est juste un problème de la dynamique aérodynamique. Nous avons développé un inflatable de cette façon. En
[SPEAKER_00]: fait, Ozone a fait un super travail. La première chose, c'est de trouver le meilleur aérodynamique. Et la deuxième chose, c'est de séparer le
[SPEAKER_00]: corps de l'aérodynamique de l'aérodynamique. Et la plupart du temps, vous avez la forme parfaite de l'aérodynamique et vous gagnez beaucoup
[SPEAKER_00]: de stabilité et pas beaucoup de boucles. Si vous avez une bonne façon de gérer le U-axe, c'est même d'améliorer le U-axe et tout le way in
[SPEAKER_00]: transition en termes de performance. Et puis, ils choisissent la meilleure forme. Et pour choisir la meilleure forme, vous devez être
[SPEAKER_00]: vraiment avec un petit segment, un segment aérodynamique qui est face à l'aile, qui devrait être le plus petit. C'est pourquoi vous avez besoin
[SPEAKER_00]: d'un matériau comme l'aéroïde pour être plus petit. Et ensuite, il faut juste choisir la forme qui est la meilleure. La flexibilité du fer,
[SPEAKER_00]: c'est ce que vous dites ? Oui, c'est ce que vous appellez un bateau. Le rouleur. Le rouleur stable. Oui, ce que nous avons fait dans notre
[SPEAKER_00]: prototype. C'est un concept merveilleux. Un paraglider, c'est une aile, des lignes et un corps avec des bras, une tête et un couteau. Si vous
[SPEAKER_00]: mettez une protection plus grande, vous augmentez la taille du cercle autour du pilote. le front de l'aérodynamique et perdre l'effet
[SPEAKER_00]: aérodynamique parce que vous avez besoin d'avoir un long aérodynamique et puis ce n'est plus pratique et nous ne sommes pas des
[SPEAKER_00]: avions d'avion nous sommes toujours des paragliders sur un backpack vous avez besoin d'avoir de la protection et je pense que le problème
[SPEAKER_00]: n'est pas Je pense que, comparé à un ferrant sur un harnais, le gain de performance est énorme. Il y a une grande différence. Un harnais normal
[SPEAKER_00]: sur un ferrant, il y a un gap. Le gap est petit comparé au gap avec un harnais comme le submarine. Donc, je pense que Le problème est que
[SPEAKER_00]: maintenant, je me souviens de 20 ans auparavant, quand on commençait à avoir Pod Harness, sauf que c'était Chargado dans les années 90, mais
[SPEAKER_00]: quand on commençait à avoir Pod Harness, les pilotes disaient que c'était seulement pour la compétition, qu'il n'allait jamais y aller,
[SPEAKER_00]: qu'il était dangereux. C'est comme quand on commence à voler accro en années 90, certaines personnes disent que c'est dangereux, que ça va
[SPEAKER_00]: tuer le sport. C'est la mauvaise façon de penser. Toutes les innovations peuvent être intéressantes. Nous devons être ouverts. Et
[SPEAKER_00]: l'ACRO aide la sécurité en paragliding. En fait, les gens pensent que c'est trop dangereux, que ça va tuer le sport. Non, l'ACRO aide la
[SPEAKER_00]: sécurité. Et je travaille tous les jours avec Tim Alonghi, le meilleur pilote. style le meilleur style et tim est un pilote merveilleux et nous
[SPEAKER_00]: aide tous les jours à améliorer la qualité de la sécurité de nos produits donc nous n'avons pas à se défendre de la révolution et ce genre
[SPEAKER_00]: d'arnaque inflatable probablement c'est notre designer de travail c'est le travail d'ingénieurs qui travaillent sur cela pour en
[SPEAKER_00]: apprendre un peu et le faire étape par étape. Peut-être qu'il reviendra aux pilotes normaux, ou peut-être pas. Il restera uniquement aux
[SPEAKER_00]: meilleurs pilotes. Mais le problème est, si maintenant nous disons qu'on augmente la taille du protecteur, pour quoi ? Pour obtenir plus de
[SPEAKER_00]: protection. Si vous augmentez la taille d'un coroïde, vous n'obtiendrez plus de protection. Vous perdrez l'efficacité du
[SPEAKER_00]: protecteur arrière. Si vous mettez un protecteur arrière de 20 cm, vous n'aurez pas un résultat meilleur qu'un protecteur arrière de 8, 9 ou 7
[SPEAKER_00]: cm. Comme je l'ai dit, vous devez crash 80% pour avoir le meilleur résultat. Avec 20%, vous ne crasherez pas 10%. Donc d'abord, vous
[SPEAKER_00]: n'obtiendrez pas de sécurité. Bien sûr, vous pouvez mettre inflatable, mais inflatable, pour atteindre la certification, vous
[SPEAKER_00]: devez être de 22 cm. Ensuite, vous aurez besoin d'augmenter le cercle autour du pilote. Et puis le pilote aura le couteau ici, à la tête. Non,
[SPEAKER_00]: vous n'avez pas besoin que le couteau soit si haut. Vous ne pouvez pas augmenter le temps pour augmenter la sécurité et ce ne sera pas utile.
[SPEAKER_00]: Vous avez besoin d'une chose facile à utiliser, qui est pratique, pas trop chaud, vous ne dépensez pas 20 minutes pour l'installer. Et c'est
[SPEAKER_00]: le travail de nos designers pour pouvoir proposer un produit dans le futur au public, qui sera bon pour voler avec sécurité. Pour le moment,
[SPEAKER_00]: c'est un des top pilotes. Et pour le moment, en termes de visibilité, ce n'est pas aussi le meilleur. C'est bon pour les pilotes G-stop, mais ce
[SPEAKER_00]: n'est pas bon. pour les pilotes normaux, alors nous devons améliorer. Ça va prendre deux ans, trois ans, cinq ans, dix ans, je ne sais pas. C'est
[SPEAKER_00]: une nouvelle aventure. C'est pourquoi nous aimons le paragliding et le design des produits en paragliding. Il y avait un jeune ingénieur
[SPEAKER_00]: d'aérodynamique qui travaillait pendant huit mois pour ce projet avec Salomé, qui est aussi ingénieur. À la fin de l'entraînement, Julien a
[SPEAKER_00]: expliqué que c'était uniquement pour les top pilotes. J'ai dit oui, pour le moment. Mais dans le futur, peut-être pas. Si je me souviens de 20
[SPEAKER_00]: ans, avec le port d'Arnès, c'était seulement pour les pilotes. Et maintenant, vous pouvez voir beaucoup de pilotes. Parce que c'est,
[SPEAKER_00]: d'abord, plus confortable. Vous pouvez marcher. Et c'est bien de voler sur un long vol cross-country. On ne parle pas de l'aérodynamique juste
[SPEAKER_00]: pour ça. C'est ça. ce concept. Just let it go and we will see what happens and what the manufacturers and designers are able to create with this
[SPEAKER_00]: new technology. Wonderful tool. Now, you've answered 10 questions that I was going to ask with this beautiful description. But while we are
[SPEAKER_01]: talking about the submarine style, I saw Maxime flying it and a few other new pilots flying this all-white, beautifully designed
[SPEAKER_01]: submarine-style harness. I'm wondering... La forme de l'aéroport a un appareil différent. De l'ozone, de la génie ou des oiseaux proches. La
[SPEAKER_01]: vallée de l'eau est en train d'apporter son bateau à l'aéroport. Tout le monde essaie d'accomplir le même motif de diminution de la pression.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alors pourquoi nous les voyons tellement différemment des autres ? Parce que, disons, les paragliders. Les paragliders, tout le monde
[SPEAKER_01]: veut atteindre moins de pression et la meilleure performance. Donc toutes les ailes du triple C ressemblent à la même chose. Mais les
[SPEAKER_01]: harnais de submarines commencent à sembler très différents d'eux-mêmes déjà. Alors, quelle est la différence entre la forme et
[SPEAKER_01]: comment les consommateurs peuvent aller acheter pour savoir quelle forme est meilleure ou quelle forme fait moins de drague ? Parce que
[SPEAKER_01]: nous, nous n'avons pas le know-how technique ou l'expertise que vous avez. Comment la décision-making vient d'un point de vue du
[SPEAKER_01]: consommateur quand il regarde ces... Dans le design du paraglider, c'est très différent. Le designer a un secret et vous ne pouvez pas le
[SPEAKER_00]: voir quand vous regardez le glider dans l'air. Il y a beaucoup de paramètres quand vous désignez une roue, ce qui fait une grande
[SPEAKER_00]: différence. Si vous n'êtes pas devant le computer avec tous les fichiers, vous ne pouvez pas le voir. Par exemple, quand on parle de
[SPEAKER_00]: profil, personne ne peut voir un profil. Même un designer, quand il voit une aiguille, il ne sait pas quel profil le designer utilise. Le profil,
[SPEAKER_00]: si tu le regardes, tu ne peux pas le voir. Tu ne peux pas le voir du haut au bas de la même manière. Tout est caché. Notre glissage est beaucoup
[SPEAKER_00]: différent de ce que nous pensons. Pour le développement de notre modèle pro pour Tim et Max, nous nous concentrons sur la meilleure performance
[SPEAKER_00]: en aérodynamique. C'était la seule façon. Nous avons essayé plus de 80 formes. et non pas des formes de prototypes AT. Nous n'avons pas le
[SPEAKER_00]: monnaie pour cela. Nous avons essayé de simuler, à l'aide d'un ordinateur, plus de formes d'AT. Et nous avons finalisé notre forme de
[SPEAKER_00]: la meilleure façon possible pour être la meilleure aérodynamique possible. Lorsque nous avons développé l'armée, le modèle est de 1,5
[SPEAKER_00]: kg. C'est généralement pour la compétition I Can Fly. Mais c'était un projet de performance. Ce n'était pas seulement pour I Can Fly, c'était
[SPEAKER_00]: un projet général de performance qui n'est pas terminé encore. L'autre avantage que nous avons, c'est qu'à Neo, depuis 10 ans, nous avons une
[SPEAKER_00]: très bonne base de géométrie d'Arnès, et une base d'Arnès qui est super stable, très agréable, très agréable à tourner. Nous avons une grande
[SPEAKER_00]: expérience avec le suspendeur en compétition. Tim et Max savent vraiment bien la géométrie de l'Arnès. Donc, le bas de notre Arnès, je
[SPEAKER_00]: considère toujours que le bas de l'Arnès est la géométrie. La géométrie est super importante. Il y a des fabricants qui ne volent même pas avec
[SPEAKER_00]: leur arnaque quand ils ont une arnaque de design. Nous, pour faire de la géométrie, comme un stand-up ou un suspendeur, nous avons passé 200
[SPEAKER_00]: heures dans l'air. C'était un long chemin de 200 ou 300 heures dans l'air pour atteindre cet objectif. Donc, nos arnaques de bâtiment étaient
[SPEAKER_00]: vraiment bonnes. Ensuite, nous avons dû mettre cette forme. Et la forme de l'extérieur était seulement... L'objectif était seulement la
[SPEAKER_00]: performance. Et je peux te le dire, quand tu as un gars comme Maxime Pinault en tant qu'ambassadeur de la marque, tu ne discutes pas
[SPEAKER_00]: beaucoup de performance. Il sait mieux que n'importe qui ce qu'est la performance d'un paraglider. Je suis d'accord. Et je pense que avoir
[SPEAKER_01]: Maxime en tant que partenaire de ton équipe dit beaucoup de choses sur ta marque. C'est une marque où tu peux essayer de faire un peu de recherche
[SPEAKER_01]: et trouver une façon de mettre ton confiance dedans. En parlant de protection du stand-up, j'ai vu que vous avez une patente ouverte pour
[SPEAKER_01]: le système de précaution du stand-up. Pouvez-vous nous parler un peu de la précaution du stand-up ? Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Comment peuvent-ils
[SPEAKER_01]: avoir cela dans leur ordinateur en une manière meilleure que la précaution conventionnelle qui vous laisse en colère ? Vous pouvez
[SPEAKER_01]: installer Rogalo, Apex, Square Rescue ou Planar Rescue, ce que vous voulez. Vous pouvez installer ce que vous voulez.
[SPEAKER_00]: J'ai commencé à développer le système Stand-Up avec Marc Boyer, l'un des pilotes les plus expérimentés de la Fédération Française pour
[SPEAKER_00]: tester les certifications. Il est aussi un pilote très expérimenté de la SIV, un pilote bien connu en France. Il était dans l'équipe française
[SPEAKER_00]: il y a longtemps. Il est vraiment un expert en sécurité et en performance en paragliding. Il est un très bon ami. Quand nous avons eu la
[SPEAKER_00]: discussion, quand il a fait la SIV, Si le pilote n'a pas le temps d'attacher ses ailes dans l'air, vous aurez un effet de miroir. Lorsque
[SPEAKER_00]: vous avez la bandoulière de l'escalier attaquée sur l'escalier, en tirant à l'arrière, et si vous avez l'aile attaquée sur les points
[SPEAKER_00]: principaux en tirant à l'avant, vous allez tomber sur votre dos. Le downplaning est assez risqué. J'ai déjà été sous downplaning une fois.
[SPEAKER_01]: La seule fois que j'ai été déployé, j'ai hâte d'avoir des carabineurs ou quelque chose comme ça. Parce que cette position n'est pas la plus
[SPEAKER_01]: confortable pour atteindre l'impact ou autre chose. Tout le monde étudie le paragliding. Personnellement, je n'aime pas quand il y a une
[SPEAKER_00]: grande roue et tout le monde suit la roue sans penser si la roue est correcte. Mais c'est la même chose dans notre monde aujourd'hui. On met
[SPEAKER_00]: des roues, les gens suivent, mais ils ne savent pas si la roue est correcte ou non. Je ne dis pas que je suis hors de la loi. Je ne suis pas un
[SPEAKER_00]: gars comme ça. Je suis en train de suivre la loi si la loi est correcte. Donc, c'est mon propre sens commun. Et puis, quand il y a une roue dans la
[SPEAKER_00]: paragliding, j'aime voir si la roue est correcte. Par exemple, dans la stabilité de l'harnais, tout le monde dit que vous devez avoir un point
[SPEAKER_00]: de portée haut. Non, pas tout le temps. Parfois oui, parfois non. C'est probablement 20% de la stabilité de l'avalanche. Il y a beaucoup
[SPEAKER_00]: d'autres facteurs, spécialement le centre de gravité. Donc, généralement, dans des activités comme le paragliding, il y a des gens
[SPEAKER_00]: qui ont de grandes règles, et ils suivent ces règles, et ils ne pensent pas qu'un jour, ils auront vérifié si la règle est correcte. Tout le
[SPEAKER_00]: monde à propos de la réscue pensait que l'attachement aux bras était le meilleur. Parce que tu t'arrêtes. Oui, mais tu t'arrêtes, tu ne peux
[SPEAKER_00]: plus bouger. Tu ne peux plus contrôler ta réscue. Tu ne peux plus tourner. Tu peux se débrouiller ici, comme ça se passe chez Team LNG. Il
[SPEAKER_00]: peut se passer de nombreuses choses. Ensuite, j'ai étudié et j'ai dit que c'était stupide cette règle d'avoir seulement les bras sur les
[SPEAKER_00]: bras. Tout le monde dit ça, donc tout le monde suit comme un chip. Et j'étais en train de penser, allons-y. Un système, parce que la plupart
[SPEAKER_00]: des pilotes ouvrent leur réscue vraiment bas. Environ... 150, 100 mètres, même 50 mètres au-dessus du sol. Donc, c'est assez bas pour
[SPEAKER_00]: récupérer une aile. Donc, généralement, il y a un effet mirage. Nous devrions avoir un système où l'effet mirage sera, au moins pour la
[SPEAKER_00]: position du pilote, le meilleur. Je mets au même endroit la rescue et l'aile, et puis je crée un système qui éteint le pilote. Il se situe dans
[SPEAKER_00]: une position de position Très droit. Et si vous voulez mettre les pieds en première place, vous pouvez. Si vous voulez garder les pieds dans
[SPEAKER_00]: l'armée, c'est super sûr. Et c'est aussi plus facile de récupérer vos ailes. Retirez vos ailes et récupérez vos ailes dans la bonne position.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pas d'effet mirror. Vous pouvez prendre vos risers pour vous tourner. Si une maison vient devant vous, ou un arbre, ou quelque chose comme ça,
[SPEAKER_00]: vous pouvez mettre votre protection devant. Ces choses font que l'expérience de faire des rescues est beaucoup plus sûre et plus
[SPEAKER_00]: confortable que pour le pilote. Ça apporte des souvenirs de l'invention de Sharknose par Ozon, où ils ont mis en place cette
[SPEAKER_01]: technologie révolutionnaire sur le marché. Et puis, les gens ont commencé à la copier parce qu'ils avaient une patente ouverte. Est-ce
[SPEAKER_01]: que nous regardons ça aussi de la part de NIO, qui est aussi beaucoup adoptée ? Comment répond le marché jusqu'à présent ? D'abord, je
[SPEAKER_00]: l'ouvre parce que la sécurité et le paragliding sont ma passion. Si je peux apporter la sécurité
[SPEAKER_00]: à ma passion, je dois être ouvert. J'ai mis un patin pour montrer aux gens que c'est un pas important en termes de sécurité. Si tu ne mets pas de
[SPEAKER_00]: patin, personne ne le voit. Donc, on a mis un patin et on a dit que c'était ouvert pour ceux qui veulent l'utiliser. Pour ceux qui veulent
[SPEAKER_00]: l'utiliser, ils ont juste à nous contacter et nous allons le mettre dans leur arnaque avec ce système à l'intérieur. Ça va prendre du temps parce
[SPEAKER_00]: que ce n'est pas un concept qui est super facile à comprendre. Donc ça va prendre du temps, étape par étape. On l'a lancé il y a moins d'un an. On a
[SPEAKER_00]: mis le pattern il y a trois ans, désolé. On a lancé le harness il y a moins d'un an. Étape par étape, les gens pensent à ça, discutent, et certaines
[SPEAKER_00]: personnes ont ce harness, le suspendeur, et ils commencent à l'utiliser dans SIV, et ensuite les instructeurs commencent à voir
[SPEAKER_00]: l'effet réel. Cela prendra du temps. Nous pensons déjà à la prochaine génération d'Harness pour l'améliorer. Tout ce genre de technologie
[SPEAKER_00]: n'est pas visible d'abord. Ce n'est pas si facile. Il faut l'expliquer. C'est assez technique. Il faut beaucoup de temps pour que le cerveau des
[SPEAKER_00]: gens l'utilise. Ce n'est pas une technologie qui fait que vous n'augmentez pas votre ratio de glissade ou que vous n'êtes pas très
[SPEAKER_00]: visible. Mais étape par étape, nous sommes plus intéressés par les gens et c'est un bon argument. Mais pour moi, quand je vends des produits,
[SPEAKER_00]: j'essaie de donner le meilleur de moi-même et de mon équipe R&D dans le produit. Parce que je ne suis pas seul, j'ai une équipe R&D avec moi. Et la
[SPEAKER_00]: philosophie de Néo est de donner le meilleur dans un vestiaire ou un sac à sac, ou un sac à sac. Et puis... Si je considère que je peux donner une
[SPEAKER_00]: meilleure sécurité,
[SPEAKER_00]: je le mets après, si les gens suivent ou n'aiment pas. Oui, je écoute, mais le plus important pour moi, c'est de donner le meilleur dans chaque
[SPEAKER_01]: produit. Je pense que c'est visible dans votre philosophie et dans la façon dont vous l'avez apporté. En termes de fin, Eric, il y a deux
[SPEAKER_01]: derniers sujets. Le premier, le caravane d'aluminium le plus sécurisé du monde, mentionné sur votre site. C'est l'objet de votre
[SPEAKER_01]: collaboration avec Australpin et Australpin Rocket. What is this about and why does it get the tag of being one of the most innovative and
[SPEAKER_01]: safest in the world on your website? How is it different from what's available on the market? Ten years ago, during the development of
[SPEAKER_00]: String 2, we had some issues with the carabiners when we made the test. Then we stopped to study and we went to the university in Annecy. We
[SPEAKER_00]: specialized in metal and materials and we stopped to make some tests and the guys, the engineer told us that the main problem with aluminium is
[SPEAKER_00]: fatigue. Yeah. Puis nous avons commencé à en étudier et nous avons découvert, nous avons fait un test avec le carabineur que nous
[SPEAKER_00]: utilisons, et 85 000 fois, après 80 000 cycles, le carabineur s'est cassé. Nous étions surpris. Et puis on a commencé à regarder autour et on
[SPEAKER_00]: a vu que je savais qu'en 2001, l'Austria Alpine avait un problème comme ça, pas dans l'air, mais sur le sol. Et puis j'y suis allé, j'ai visité eux
[SPEAKER_00]: et j'ai dit qu'on devait faire quelque chose de plus sûr. Et puis ils m'ont dit qu'on devait augmenter la taille d'un cylindre de 8
[SPEAKER_00]: millimètres au début du carabineur. Quand on le fabrique, on va passer à 10 millimètres. Et puis nous devons bloquer le problème de fatigue avec
[SPEAKER_00]: un système qu'ils appellent Autolock. vous pouvez aller sur notre site web pour voir exactement ce dessin. Et en plus de cela, nous avons vu
[SPEAKER_00]: aussi que le nouvel arnais, la précaution frontale pour quand vous avez un « I can fly » ou la taille du réservoir a diminué. Il y a eu beaucoup de
[SPEAKER_00]: choses autour de la forme du carabineur, ce qui fait qu'il le rend plus fragile. Si vous prenez un carabineur square, et on a mis de l'aluminium
[SPEAKER_00]: sur le carabineur, et on a mis de l'aluminium sur le carabineur, et on a mis de l'aluminium sur le carabineur, et on a mis de l'aluminium sur le
[SPEAKER_00]: carabineur, et on a mis de l'aluminium sur le carabineur, et on a mis de l'aluminium sur le carabineur, et on a mis de l'aluminium sur le
[SPEAKER_00]: carabineur, et on a mis de l'aluminium sur le carabineur,
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est pourquoi nous avons développé un carabineur avec une marque austrienne, une pin austrienne. Nous avons ajouté l'exclusivité pour
[SPEAKER_00]: les premiers deux ou trois ans de vente et puis nous l'avons ouvert au marché. Dans le paragliding, c'est la seule chose dans le paragliding
[SPEAKER_00]: qui n'est pas certifiée en termes de puissance. Arnais, rescues, barres, glides, tout est certifié, sauf le carabineur. Je ne sais pas.
[SPEAKER_00]: Donc, vous avez des carabineurs de climat qui sont certifiés. Donc, nous faisons cette certification. Mais en fait, le climat n'a pas
[SPEAKER_00]: d'effet de fatigue. Parce qu'il n'y a pas d'intention. Ils tombent juste. Mais pour prévenir ce risque de détruire les carabineurs à cause
[SPEAKER_00]: de la fatigue, il n'y a pas de certification. Il n'y a pas de certification pour les carabineurs. C'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
[SPEAKER_00]: à Néo de essayer de fabriquer le meilleur, on l'appelle le carabineur le plus sain. Et c'est un peu plus élevé que le carabineur. J'ai deux
[SPEAKER_00]: filles. Elles sont la graisse de ma vie. Elles sont la chose la plus importante de ma vie. Et je ne veux pas qu'elles perdent leur père. Donc,
[SPEAKER_00]: j'ai préféré porter plus de carabineurs et revenir en sécurité. Et puis, quand ils ont découvert ça, la fédération, la fédération
[SPEAKER_00]: allemande, la fédération française, ils ont décidé de dire aux gens, au moins, changez-le chaque 500 heures, ou au moins, changez-le chaque 5
[SPEAKER_00]: ans. Cela éviterait le plus de risques. Mais en plus, nous avons fait ce carabineur pour cela. C'est très important. Ça m'étonne quand Dynema
[SPEAKER_01]: est tellement plus puissant, pourquoi n'a-t-on pas changé l'industrie vers Dynema en tant que remplacement pour les carabineurs
[SPEAKER_01]: ? Et comment les carabineurs ont-ils plus confiance en ce qui est disponible si facilement ? J'ai toujours considéré qu'au
[SPEAKER_00]: développement des produits, il n'y a pas de solution magique. Vous avez une solution pour chaque problème, pour chaque façon d'utiliser les
[SPEAKER_00]: roues. Le connecteur Dynema est bon. Par exemple, quand vous allez climber sur des montagnes, vous êtes dans une piste très étroite, et
[SPEAKER_00]: vous devez mettre votre arnaque. Si vous ne pouvez pas ouvrir votre pantalon, vous devez le mettre comme un pantalon, alors il devient
[SPEAKER_00]: vraiment risqué. Surtout si vous avez les crampons. Si vous avez un connecteur, c'est beaucoup plus difficile d'ouvrir le pantalon.
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est mieux d'avoir un carabineur. Dyneema est très bon, mais ça ne correspond pas à toute la façon d'utiliser. Je n'aime pas les gens qui
[SPEAKER_00]: viennent, comme par exemple, bien sûr, je considère le corroid comme la meilleure protection. sur le marché. Mais maintenant, nous lançons
[SPEAKER_00]: une permère de Skywalk pour Inflatable, parce que nous avons une très bonne relation avec Jeanne, mais aussi avec Skywalk. Nous sommes
[SPEAKER_00]: vraiment amis avec ces deux marques. Et Skywalk, nous l'utilisons pour les lèvres extra-paranés, pour les lèvres. Je ne considère pas que
[SPEAKER_00]: Choroïd est la meilleure technologie, mais je ne dis pas que c'est bon pour tout. Je vais utiliser Permair. Pour ce genre d'utilisation,
[SPEAKER_00]: Permair est meilleur que Choroïd. Et pour d'autres utilisations, Choroïd est meilleur que Permair. J'aime être open-minded et choisir
[SPEAKER_00]: la façon que j'aime et que je suis libre d'utiliser. Et c'est pareil pour le développement de produits. Si vous allez seulement une seule façon,
[SPEAKER_00]: Un jour, vous serez en erreur. Par exemple, je n'étais pas en faveur du ferry et des choses comme ça. Et maintenant, j'ai découvert que c'est
[SPEAKER_00]: bon. Donc, nous aurons un ferry dans le futur, dans la table d'art. Moi, personnellement, non, parce que je n'en suis pas fière. Mais je vois, en
[SPEAKER_00]: discutant avec Maxime, avec Tim, avec les ingénieurs, qu'il y a une possibilité. Donc, j'ai changé de tête et nous allons aller dans cette
[SPEAKER_00]: direction aussi. J'adore ça, mec. Je pense que c'est l'idéologie derrière ton succès. Avant de te laisser partir, ça ne pourrait pas être
[SPEAKER_01]: une technologie révolutionnaire, mais ça m'a attiré l'œil et je pense qu'il vaut la peine de parler à nos auditeurs. Qu'est-ce que c'est que le
[SPEAKER_01]: NEO ? Qu'est-ce que c'est que le nouveau NEO Dyneema Ripstop ? C'est une autre chose que tu as inventée ou c'est juste une customisation qui suit
[SPEAKER_01]: les besoins de paragliding ? Ou si tu peux parler un peu plus sur ça. C'était ma start-up avec des fabriques non-weaving. Je ne suis pas sûr,
[SPEAKER_00]: je serai heureux de vous le présenter. Vous avez une fabrique qui a un nom. C'était une fabrique fabriquée aux Etats-Unis. Et le nom, je ne me
[SPEAKER_00]: souviens pas. J'ai perdu un grand trou dans ma mémoire. Et il n'avait pas de mouillage. Donc, quand vous les suivez, vous devez les taper parce
[SPEAKER_00]: qu'il était en bruit. C'était à l'eau, mais pas flexible. L'âge n'était pas si bon. Il y avait beaucoup de problèmes. Et puis, certains
[SPEAKER_00]: fabricants ont commencé à travailler sur le dynamisme. comme un rip-stop basé sur les matériaux. Nous avons donc décidé d'aller voir.
[SPEAKER_00]: Il n'y a que deux entreprises en Europe qui sont capables de mouiller un ferret, de mouiller un dynamite, et l'une d'entre elles est notre
[SPEAKER_00]: partenaire. Nous avons décidé de les visiter et de vérifier ce que nous pouvons faire. Nous avons finalement mis une fabrique de polyamide
[SPEAKER_00]: avec le ripstop de Dyneema. Avec la bonne couche et le bon calendrier, nous avons découvert que pour la même touche de fabrique, nous ayons
[SPEAKER_00]: gagné 70% du poids, ou au moins 50%. C'est seulement 110 grammes. Normalement, ce type de fabrique, pour être si forte, c'est 150 à 350
[SPEAKER_00]: grammes. Nous avons découvert qu'il n'y avait pas d'élasticité, qu'il y avait de la réparation d'eau, pas complètement d'eau. Nous pouvons la
[SPEAKER_00]: nettoyer. Il n'y avait pas de marques quand vous les mettez dans votre arnaque. Donc, nous avons développé ce matériau avec Catalan, ce
[SPEAKER_00]: manufacturier de Barcelone. Le problème principal de cette fabrique est comparé à une fabrique de sac à paraglider normale. C'est 5 fois plus
[SPEAKER_00]: cher. Nous avons des coûts de travail et des matériaux qui sont très élevés. C'est pour cela que nos prix sont un peu plus élevés. Mais si vous
[SPEAKER_00]: voulez avoir des coûts de travail élevés, vous avez besoin du matériau le meilleur. Vous ne pouvez pas faire de matériaux chers. C'est pour
[SPEAKER_00]: cela que nous avons décidé d'utiliser ce matériau et c'est l'une des clés du succès. En fait, votre marque est innovante dans les petites
[SPEAKER_01]: choses et la partage sur un public plus large, parce que ces choses sont inventées, sont vues dans tous vos accessoires, comme le harnais et le
[SPEAKER_01]: neoprotecteur. L'hermite est un peu une surprise. Comment une marque de paragliding peut s'adapter à l'hermite aussi ? Je pense qu'à ce
[SPEAKER_01]: point, Eric, nous avons couvert tout sur mon part. Est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose que vous voudriez mettre à l'écran ? Non, juste ça. Les
[SPEAKER_00]: gens qui travaillent au Néo, la plupart des gens qui travaillent au Néo et nos athlètes, comme Jean-Yves Frédéricsen, Climb K2, nous
[SPEAKER_00]: travaillons ensemble depuis plus de 10 ans, Maxime Pinault, Tim Allongy, et il y a aussi Laurie, Laurie Genovese, qui ont tous une grande
[SPEAKER_00]: passion pour la montagne, et non seulement le paragliding, mais aussi le ski et le climat. Et pour les gens au Néo, c'est pareil, nous vivons
[SPEAKER_00]: dans la même zone et nous partageons les sports dans la montagne. Nous aimons les produits, et les produits beaux, c'est ce que j'ai appris de
[SPEAKER_00]: Jean. Jeanne m'a toujours dit qu'une aiguille magnifique va toujours voler mieux qu'une aiguille qui ne ressemble pas à une aiguille. Donc
[SPEAKER_00]: nous essayons de faire des produits magnifiques et nous essayons d'abord de faire des produits pour nous. Nous ne suivons pas seulement
[SPEAKER_00]: le trend de marketing, nous faisons des produits que nous aimons utiliser. C'est notre but principal. Parfois, nous ne suivons pas les
[SPEAKER_00]: trends, mais nous essayons d'être authentiques dans la façon de designer et de produire. C'est le plus important. J'adore ça. Plus de
[SPEAKER_01]: pouvoir pour toi et des marques comme toi. De tous ceux et celles de Panadar Atlas, je vous souhaite de la chance. Continuez à rocker et à
[SPEAKER_01]: créer de la magie. Merci de nous avoir partagé. Merci.